artist and environmentalist Cyrus Kabira
is both growing up on the mean streets
of Nairobi ski bear Aslam he discovered
something beautiful in the middle of all
the squalor most of the games that they
used to come and chill in my studio
relax and then you'll get their changing
because of my walk
they're changing my work is changing
them
Cyrus his passion for eyewear began when
he was a boy now he creates beauty out
of trash everything deserves a second
chance in life even junk Cyrus says
spending more time at rubbish dumps
hunting for materials than at school
didn't go down well anywhere in Kenya if
you can if you don't perform well in
high school people treat you like you a
loser they are making us to hit our life
like we are not encouraging us like our
future an artist community in Nairobi
has been Cyrus kuvira's home for a while
here he's made friends like fellow
artists misako yarrow who accept him the
way he is for the better but he is
easygoing but there's a key element of
difficulty in him he is a funny
character very fine indeed they can make
you laugh when you don't want to laugh
you can laugh when it's not mostly
appropriate
that's the kind of person is cyrus is
also a serious businessman his unique
artworks become hugely popular they can
fetch up to $1,000 apiece on the art
market as a being I'm trying to fight
you like I want you to buy my wall
because you'd like it and I want you to
buy my wife cause what you want to
handle me so that's why I'm saying like
you're too much poverty selling poverty
than creativity
electronic refuse and other recycled
material takes on a new life in Cyrus's
work now he hopes negotiators at the
Paris climate talks will hear his
powerful environmental message and
experience it firsthand there's a
climate change conference in Paris this
year and I was selected we are doing an
exhibition of one artist one country one
at work so I've been selected this year
to be to represent Kenya cyrus is
convinced his funky eye art will make a
splash at the climate summit not bad for
a boy from Kibera slum who resisted
societal pressure and only did what he
enjoyed most